AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
SUPER MARIOLD.
>> OH, MAN.
THIS MAKES ME FEEL OLD.
THIS MONTH MARKS THE 30TH
ANNIVERSARY OF "SUPER MARIO
BROS." IT'S A-ME! MIDLIFE
CRISIS MARIO!
>> INSTEAD OF MUSHROOMS, NOW HE
EATS TRUFFLES!
>> TO CELEBRATE THE MILESTONE,
NINTENDO IS RELEASING A LEVEL
CREATOR, "SUPER MARIO MAKER," SO
HE CAN SPEND HIS TIME JUMPING
OVER A MILLION BRICK PENISES.
AFTER THREE DECADES THERE
MUST BE A TON WE DON'T
KNOW ABOUT MARIO'S INNER LIFE,
LIKE WHERE DO YOU EVEN BUY
BRIGHT RED OVERALLS? AND ARE YOU
STILL ACTUALLY A PLUMBER? SO
COMEDIANS, TO CELEBRATE HIS
BIG 3-0 I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
SOME LESSER-KNOWN MARIO FACTS.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND
BEGIN.
>> PAUL.
>> HE'S-A ME!
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES.
ANDREA SAVAGE.
>> HE ACTUALLY WROTE THE
ORIGINAL SCREENPLAY TO "PITCH
PERFECT 2."
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> BEFORE HE GETS INTO HIS MARIO
KART, HE SPRAYS HIS ENTIRE
MOUTH WITH SILVER PAINT.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ANDREA SAVAGE.
>> HE HAD SEX BUT PREFERS
(BLEEP)ING PIPES.
>> Chris: OKAY.
POINTS.
JAMES URBANIAK.
>> THAT'S NOT A MUSTACHE, IT IS
A FUZZY TUMOR.
>> Chris: POINTS. ANDREA SAVAGE.
>> HE LOVES TO LAUGH.
>> Chris: JUST LOVES IT.
UNFORTUNATELY, NOT THE CROWD.
NO POINTS. JAMES URBANIAK.
>> NOT INTO ZEPPELIN.
>> POINTS.